i think lamar alexander embodies that
as president of the university of
tennessee as a governor
as the secretary of education as a
senator
in every one of those jobs it's always
been about
doing his best in a chamber filled with
people who
think they have a monopoly on wisdom
lamar has never
stopped learning he's always been
curious
up to this day i'll bet today he
probably got up and
asked somebody on his staff or some one
of his colleagues
to tell him about something that he
wants to
so he can do his best
the senate is going to be diminished by
lamar's absence
it's hard to believe that we could be
any more diminished than we are
but we are going to be diminished by
lamar
leaving susan and i
were lucky enough to be invited to his
home
spend a weekend there and i'm just
i'm going to say something now that i
never said to lamar alexander but
he gave us the great privilege of
standing in
the family cemetery in eastern tennessee
in the smoky his beloved smoky mountains
where
he will forever keep the windmills out
and as i stood there a little awkwardly
in the in the cemetery
because that's not usually part of a
tour
all i could think about was how lucky
lamar
and honey were
to know that that would be the place
that they
would be
and that long after they were remembered
by anybody that
they would know that they had done their
best
that they had always done their best
and so what i would say to my colleagues
today is that
we have an opportunity to to follow
lamar's example
take him up on what he said
we're not memorializing lamar today he's
going to have
a lot more years left to contribute to
his state to his community
and to the country but he won't be in
the senate
and we are in the senate
we could work in a senate that works
five days a week
mr president or even six days a week
mr president sign me up for that senate
we could work in a senate that has 25
amendments a bill
instead of 25 amendments in a year
as we did last year because there is no
other body in america or in this
democracy as lamar
said that set up
to decide the hardest questions that our
country is facing
and to make those decisions
for us today
he's left us with a challenge
and i hope we'll take them up on it
because there there is no excuse for the
way this place
works and the american people
are tired of hearing that it's the other
side's fault
there are a hundred people that can fix
this place
and i hope we will i can't think of a
greater legacy for
lamar to leave than a senate that's
actually working
that's what the country deserves and
that's the inspiration that lamar
alexander
has set for me thank you mr president
senator from texas
mr president we all know lamar alexander
is a
person a tremendous character in
judgment
and it's not just because he asked that
young woman in the red shorts
that he met at that softball game so
many years ago to marry him who happens
to be from victoria texas
that demonstrates his enormous good
judgment
and certainly we wish him and and honey
the best
in this next chapter of their lives but
when i think about lamar alexander i
think about all the lamar
isms all this we've heard some of them
here today
um but uh find the good and praise it
quotes his friend alex haley which i
think speaks to a kind of optimistic
positive view of life that we could use
more of
and then i remember the words he uh he
said if you want to get
a standing ovation before any group
of individuals you need to say
it's time to put the teaching of
american history and civics back into
its rightful place
in our schools so our children could
grow up learning what it means
to be an american
well he talked about the alex haley his
friend
told him how to give a speech by telling
a story
aristotle had an idea about how to give
a great speech
he basically broke it down to three
components one is
the logical argument the other is the
emotional argument but the other
is about establishing your authority but
it's about the character
of the speaker and when i think about
lamar as he's demonstrated again here
today
the thing that i appreciate about him
the most
is not just what he's accomplished here
but his incredible character
and positive impact on our
on our senate and on our country and
it's been because people know that his
heart is in the right place he's doing
it for all the right reasons
that we admire him so much
i would just point out as i've told
lamar previously i
i was an admirer of lamar alexander long
before i ever met him
when i voted for him in the republican
primary in 1996
for president unfortunately he dropped
out
of that race shortly thereafter so i
told him i wasted my vote
obviously but i have been an admirer for
a long time
well
lamar and i also share
something else in common um
it's not about his pre well it is about
his predecessor as well as mine it's a
person by the name of sam houston
i occupy the senate seat first held by
sam houston when texas became
a state of course he
came originally from tennessee he
happened to be a governor of tennessee
before he left
and came to texas later was became
governor of texas
and seceded and basically stepped down
because he was a union man
recruited by andrew jackson he wanted
he loved the union he did not agree with
secession
but of course he came to texas and
became the victorious general at the
decisive battle
of san jacinto he became president of
the republic of texas
the same reason the reason why the texas
flag and the american flag fly at the
same height
it's because we were an independent
nation before we came
became part of the united states
well i've heard it said that you could
never write a novel based on the life of
sam houston because nobody would believe
it
i've read plenty about him and i still
find that to be true
but as i indicated as proud as texans
are
of sam houston's contribution to our
history
and our state we know we can't claim him
entirely
because he grew up in maryville
tennessee
the same town that lamar alexander did
and went on to become governor as i
mentioned a moment ago
sam houston's portrait hangs above my
desk here in the heart office building
because it helps me remind it helps
remind me of my
responsibilities and of the incredible
history
and contribution that he made
and that hopefully each of us can make
well you find
sam houston's picture above my desk
but you find his walking stick in lamar
alexander's office just down the hall
the many tennesseans who visited lamar
during his time in the chamber
have seen the word sam houston texas and
lone star engraved
on its gold cap and according to lamar
several texas have tried to
run off with it unfortunately that
hasn't been successful
the truth of the matter is you can't get
through a texas history class or at
least you shouldn't without hearing the
role
of the volunteer state in the history of
my state
i always kid lamar said the tennesseans
that came to texas that
fought at the alamo in the battle of san
jacinto
they were just one step ahead of a
creditor
or an aggrieved spouse it was a rough
and tumble group that came from
tennessee
to found texas
well there are other tennesseans people
like david crockett
others who came to texas and created our
state
the state of texas has many reasons to
be grateful to the contributions of the
sons and daughters of tennessee
and one of those great sons is lamar
this dedicated life in public service as
we know has led him through an
incredible
number of important offices
but i think the thing that to me even
more than his legislative
accomplishments that's
made lamar so effective is because we
know we can trust him
we know his character we know when he
says something it's true
and we've seen time and time again when
lamar has used that
character and that trust to pass
historic legislation
in this in this chamber
and as we've all come to know when
you're working side by side with lamar
on legislation you're bound to get
things done
because he's cracked to code he knows
how to do it
i've been proud to work with lamar on
legislation to address the opioid
epidemic support our service members and
veterans
protect health coverage and ensure folks
across the country
have the opportunity to take advantage
of the american dream
his presence has been a constant has
been constant throughout
our time we came to the senate at the
same time and of course his retirement
makes that all bittersweet so i want to
thank
our colleague from tennessee for his
friendship
over many years for the example as we
heard from senator thune and others
his example that he has shown for the
rest of us how to be an effective
member of the united states senate and
also to thank him for his decades of
service
to the country so i don't expect lamar
to
follow in the footsteps of sam houston
and run for governor of texas
but i know he has many more
contributions to make
to our great country and i want to wish
him
and honey all the best during this next
chapter
of their lives and to make sure that
and i'm sure he's looking forward to
spending a little more time
in their beloved smoky mountains
mr president senator from washington mr
president thank you
i've learned in my time in the senate
that if you want to get something done
across the aisle you really need
the following you need someone on the
other side
who's just as committed to working
together as you are
and that that member needs to have the
trust of members
on your side of the aisle and on their
own
and you both need to be willing to set
aside egos
and listen and get a realistic
understanding of whether the person on
the other side of the negotiating table
can reach an agreement with you
that upholds your principles without
compromising
their own and now what i've laid out
might not sound that
unusual or rare it's actually pretty
tough to find these days
so i've been very lucky that the senator
that we are honoring today here on the
floor
my colleague and friend chairman lamar
alexander
from tennessee is someone who has
managed it
time and time and time again
i don't think anyone least of all
senator alexander himself would be
surprised to hear me say that
we are as likely to disagree as agree on
many matters i bring my washington state
values to the table
he brings his tennessee values so you
can imagine how
that has gone from time to time but
despite our different perspectives and
our different approaches
we take to policy making we've also been
able to see where our
values and the interests of our state
and our country
converge we both understood the broken
no child left behind law needed to be
fixed
and lamar listened to me which i so
appreciated
when i told them we should write a bill
together rather than amending the
republican bill that he began working on
with our help committee members we were
able to write
and pass a new k-12 public education
bill
that fixed the most broken parts of no
child left behind
included federal guard rails so we could
understand how all of our students
perform
dedicated resources to improving our
schools that need it the most
and allowed for historic steps forward
on early education
we laid the groundwork together for new
investments in life-saving biomedical
innovation
and research through the 21st century
cures act including the bo biden cancer
moonshot
we work together to pass landmark
legislation to boost
our response to the opioid epidemic and
to strengthen our public health
preparedness programs
and to permanently fund historically
black colleges and universities
and minor minority serving institutions
we not only
passed each of these bills but did so
time and again with huge majorities from
the senate
and even still now chairman alexander
and i along with our colleagues in the
house are working to get legislation to
finally ban surprise medical bills
across the finish line
now what i've just laid out is by no
means a full list
at all of senator alexander's
accomplishments as chairman
it doesn't even include quite a few
things he's still trying to get done as
we speak right now
senator alexander's focus on working
together has helped
countless families countless families in
his home state of tennessee
in my home state of washington and
nationwide
my democratic colleagues and i want to
thank chairman alexander
for the tone and manner by which he has
led the help committee over the past six
years
some of them admittedly rockier than
others
but throughout guided by his steady
leadership
and commitment to working together
and for myself as someone who shares the
drive to not only fight for what you
believe in
but also to look for common ground i
want to thank my colleague
from tennessee for the many
opportunities
to dig in and get to work that he's
provided
for being willing to hear me and my
colleagues out again
and again and again when necessary
and for looking so often for common
ground
for another problem we could solve
and for being willing not just to keep
talking but to keep
listening as well
and finally i know mr president that
none of this would be possible without
the support and strength senator
alexander has received
from his wife honey and i want to
acknowledge
and thank her for her contribution as
well
lamar you'll be thrilled to be back
full-time in the state you love so much
i know that but i and members of the
help committee
want you to know we are going to miss
you terribly
here in the senate thank you so much for
all you have done
thank you mr president mr president
senator from mississippi
i ask unanimous consent that senators
can't well blunt
romney schumer and i be able to complete
our remarks
before the next vote is there objection
without objection
i thank you mr president and i don't
want to prolong
this discussion uh except to make one
additional point
about the unselfishness and humility
of of this hero
of the senate whose remarks we will long
remember today there is a framed
piece of legislation hanging on the wall
in my conference room in the dirksen
building
it is in fact a piece of legislation
that senator alexander uh chose to
mention
as one of his signature accomplishments
and that is the american civics
and history education act signed into
law by president george w bush
there's a story about how i came to have
that piece of legislation that senator
alexander worked so hard on
um in in my conference room
on my wall i was um i'm i live in north
mississippi and as such i
listened to memphis television a lot and
during
lamar alexander's first race for senator
owen came a commercial and basically it
said
just what our friend from texas just
quoted that
this candidate for senator former
governor lamar alexander
wanted to pass an american civic
education bill to
teach our children what it means to be
an american and i
stopped at that moment and i pointed to
that television screen and i said if
that man gets elected i want to be part
of that bill because that's exactly what
we need and so
senator alexander introduced the bill
here in the senate i introduced it
in the house of representatives we made
public appearances together one in
memphis tennessee
that i'll always remember and eventually
the bill
uh gained a lot of support over here and
senator kennedy has been mentioned as uh
as someone
at the forefront of that effort we were
able to pass it in the house
it went to conference to to iron out the
details
and a decision had to be made as to
which one would actually be enacted
by both houses and go to the president
for his signature
and lamar alexander allowed
the piece of legislation introduced by a
relatively
junior member of the house named roger
wicker to be that piece of legislation
that went on
to the white house to the oval office to
be signed
by the president of the united states
and
uh so that is how that
piece of legislation hangs um
on my wall as a bill authored
by representative roger wicker but uh
passed very much with the efforts of
senator alexander also
and so i just wanted to mention that not
to prolong
this discussion but mention that act of
selflessness
and humility as another attribute
to this great senator who we say
farewell
to today uh i think
mr president that the remarks we heard
from senator alexander
will be taught at civics classes
college-level
government classes for decades and
decades to come it was so profound
and it is a real honor that
a piece of legislation that he and i
worked on together
will always be a part of what i consider
to be those
immortal remarks and so i thank you very
much and i yield the floor
mr president the senator from washington
mr president i come to the floor too
to thank the senator from tennessee for
his service to our nation
and for his work here in the united
states senate
some of my colleagues have already
mentioned that the brevity of words at
which
senator alexander can deliver a message
i i too remember his
comments at uh as a rules committee
member the inaugural address really
capturing the moment of why a transition
of power
is so important to our nation and it
struck me that
we really had a poet or a writer among
us someone who could sense and feel the
moment of what we were going through and
express it into words so
i have no doubt that some writing is in
lamar's future here
and i look forward to seeing that but i
wanted to rise today to thank him for
his service
and what it has meant to my state and to
our nation my colleague
from washington talked about their work
together on the help committee i too
want to thank you for the cares act and
i remember your recognition on fox news
about stem cell
research and the great work that that
has led to so we are appreciative of
those
research dollars but i want to focus on
a role that maybe has not gotten as much
attention
the historic role you've played on our
energy budget
and our national laboratory budget i so
appreciate the background of your state
and the background focus but
energy funding both from the national
laboratory perspective
has had to have a constant flow and
constantly it's been challenged
yet it has put every step forward
because of the level of investment in
helping us make our nation more secure
create more innovation and create more
jobs so thank you for holding steadfast
on the national laboratory budget i also
want to thank you
for your work on the manhattan
historical park that we worked together
on that both commemorated the history of
our nation
and our manhattan project at both oak
ridge and
at richland washington at hanford and
to just thank you for the constant focus
on the cleanup budget
that we have had to have in the energy
department as it related to hanford
you know there was a time when we had
many cleanup projects around the nation
and it was very easy to come together
and say we had to get savannah river we
had to get oak ridge we had to get
colorado we had to get idaho and we had
to get hanford but as those progress
projects made progress a lot of people
forgot about what it took to clean up
hanford
and so i so appreciate your constant
focus on helping us
get the dollars necessary for cleanup at
hanford
and i also appreciate recently your help
on making sure that people didn't
overstep on the
national nuclear security agency
and turn that over to a defense
oversight
of people but kept it within the
department of energy i so appreciate
that
but i will be forever grateful for your
focus on public lands
you know we have a saying in my state
environmentalists make great ancestors
so don't know if you want that
environmentalist term
associated with your name but i'm pretty
sure you do want stewardship
and the man from the great smoky
mountains helped us
deliver a monumental piece of
legislation
by convincing the president of the
united states
to support the budgetary impact of
combining
both the national park
enhancement program which is basically
taking care of the national parks
backlog
which was in the billions of dollars and
also
fully funding the land and water
conservation fund a battle that had been
going on
for more than a decade so i want to
thank you for that lamar i want to thank
you on behalf of the washingtonians who
will go to so many special places
who will get to visit and commune with
their families
who will be able to have outdoor
experiences who will be able to
really understand the grandeur of mother
earth
and so thank you for pulling off what
seemed to be
like an impossible effort to convince
people to make that level of investment
we're going to miss the harmony of your
voice
and the harmony of your legislative
skills but we're not going to say
permanently goodbye to you
because we hope that you will be sending
us messages just like the one you sent
today
and reminding us that we can do better
so thank you lamar for your contribution
in a lot of your life to these very
important
issues that affect so many of us thank
you mr president
senator from utah i first met lamar
alexander in 1995 when he spoke
at boston's lincoln day dinner like
today he
was folksy good humored thoughtful
and impressive i remarked to anne that
he was surely going to go places of
course he'd already gone places by then
but he ran for president the next year
one thing lamar and i agree
on is the best candidate for president
does not always win
i